نحن داخل مقر الجيش في الساعه السابعه
والنصف صباحا المواقع العسكريه في رستوف
بما في ذلك المطار تحت السيطره اوروبا
اصبح من الصعب جدا فرض العقوبات على روسيا
وسلاح روسي جديد لا يترك للجيش الاوكراني
واشنطن تعلن تحديها للنووي الروسي بقرار
صارم اوباما يدخل خط الحرب الاوكرانيه
والكريم لن يرحب السوق السوداء للاسلحه
الغربيه للاوكرانيين تظهر في اسرائيل فما
الذي اوصلها الى هنا
والمفوضيه الاوروبيه تعلن موعد انضمام
اوكرانيا للاتحاد الاوروبي وجيش الدلافين
الروسي يتعهد بحمايه شبه جزيره القرم
وبطريقتها الخاصه هي تستعد الانفجار اكبر
المحطه النوويه ليقع الاوروبيون في ورطه
وبعد محاوله انقاذ علاقاتها بالصين واشنطن
تقدم على امر خطير والسودان يغلق حدوده
وفي الوقت الذي تشتعل فيه المعارك ضد
الفلسطينيين اردوغان يمد يد السلام الى
اسرائيل
تكتيك روسي من الحرب البارده
جلبه امريكيه التحركات لا تتوقف النقاشات
ترفع حدتها امر ما يحير الامريكان
ويصدع رؤوسهم نعم انه النووي الروسي ويال
هذه الكلمه الممله التي لطالما كررناها
منذ بدايه الحرب الاوكرانيه والتي ارهقت
اعصاب الغربيين لتجد واشنطن الحل لهذا
السلاح حيث اعد اعضاء مجلس شيوخ الامريكي
مشروع قرار ينص على اعتبار استخدام روسيا
المحتمل للسلاح النووي التكتيكي في
اوكرانيا امرا مساويا للهجوم على حلف
الناتو مهلا مهلا يبدو ان الامر لم يتضح
لكم جيدا هذا القرار الامريكي يعني انه في
حال استخدمت موسكو سلاح النووي ضد
اوكرانيا فان الناتو سيفعل الماده الخامسه
ويعلن الحرب التي يخشاها العالم باسره على
الدب الروسي انا لا ارى ذلك ممكنا ولا شك
انها تهديدات امريكيه عابره في عين
الاعتبار مساحه روسيا الشاسعه والتي تعدل
مساحه الولايات المتحده واوروبا مجتمعتين
والذي قد يساعد في تفادى اضرار الهجمات
النوويه فلنعد الى موضوعنا في الحرب
الاوكرانيه حيث استخدم الروس تكتيكا من
الحرب البارده وبحسب الاستخبارات
البريطانيه فان روسيا تستخدم التلفون لردع
الغواصين عن قاعده بحريه في القرن هذه
الدلافين تتميز بكونها اذكى حيوان بحري
وهي الاقرب لذكاء الانسان والتي تستخدم في
مهام تجسسيه والدفاعيه حيث تستطيع رصد
الغواصات والالغام والغواصين المعادين
والزرع متفجرات في سفن الاعداء وارسال
معلومات عن حاله الطقس والماء فعن اي جيش
مدرب نتحدث وباقل الخسائر ومن دلفين البحر
الى قوه الجو حيث ذكرت صحيفه بيلد
الالمانيه ان السلاح الطيران الروسي لا
يترك اي فرصه للجيش الاوكراني للمناوره وت
صحيفه الى ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تعاني من العجز في قدرات الدفاع الجوي ولا
يتوفر لديها طيران خاص بها بالاضافه لذلك
نسبه الجنود المجهزين بمعدات عسكريه غربيه
لا تتجاوز عشره الى 15% فقط بينما اعترف
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه الكسندر
سيرسكي بان القوات المسلحه الروسيه تتنبا
مسبقا بتحركات الجيش الاوكراني وتبني
دفاعات يصعب التغلب عليها وفق صحيفه
جارديان فهل يعني ذلك انتهاء الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد لتعلن وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه تحرير قريه سادوفويياه في منطقه
توكماك بمقاطعه زابوريجيا ومدينه اروجينوي
في جمهوريه دوناتسك نافيه مزاعم قواتك ياف
باستعادتهما وهنا جاء الدور على الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما والذي ظل
بعيدا عن الازمه الاوكرانيه وها هو يصرح
بان الكثير من سكان شبه ج
الناطقين باللغه الروسيه كانوا يؤيدون
فكره انضمام شبه الجزيره الى روسيا عام
2014 لياتي الرد الروسي على لسان الناطق
باسم
بقوله بان تصريح اوباما حمل بذورا عقلانيه
في طياته لننتقل الى اسرائيل التي اعلنت
عن سبب عدم امدادها لكياف
حيث كشف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
عن ظهور اسلحه غربيه على حدود اسرائيل
تسربت من اوكرانيا وها نحن نتصفح المصدر
الذي نشر هذا الخبر حيث تم نشره في وكاله
العالميه فيما اشار النيتن ياهو الى ان
ذلك يؤكد صواب قرار تل ابيب عدم الانجرار
الى نزاع اوكرانيا اي ان اسرائيل تخشى ان
تمد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه فتجد اسلحتها عادت
لطباعه على اراضيها في السوق السوداء فيال
العجاب وهناك صرح المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ديمتري بيسكوف بان مشكله انتشار اسلحه
الناتو المورده الى اوكرانيا في جميع
انحاء العالم اصبحت مشكله حقيقيه وواقعا
ملموسا وبينما وسع الاتحاد الاوروبي
عقوباته ضد وسائل الاعلام الروسيه وحضر بث
خمس قنوات اضافيه اقرت رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه
ارسولاين بصعوبه الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فرض العقوبات ضد روسيا وهنا تعلن
اوروبا فراغ مخزن رشاش العقوبات التي
تطلقها تجاه روسيا ومن هناك اطلقت
فونديرلايين موعد انضمام اوكرانيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي بقولها انها لا تتصور الاتحاد
الاوروبي خلال الثلاثين عاما المقبله بدون
اوكرانيا فيه هي شيخه باتله سنه مش هيكون
في اوكرانيا من اصله لا مؤاخذه مش انا
اللي قلت ده بوتين اللي بيقول من جانبها
ردت روسيا على حزمه العقوبات الاوروبيه
الجديده بعقوبات جوابيه واعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه انها زادت عدد ممثل
الاتحاد الاوروبي الممنوعين من دخول روسيا
وبالعوده الى اوكرانيا فقد اكد وزير
الداخليه ايغور كليمنكو ان كيا بدات فعليا
اجراءات احترازيه لمواجهه اي تسرب اشعاعي
محتمل بمحطه زابوريجيا بينها نشر فرق تفحص
باستمرار مستوى الاشعاعي المنطقه المحيطه
بمحطه زابوريتا النوويه التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا حاليا كما اعلن الوزير الاوكراني
بدء نقل المواطنين الراغبين في مغادره
المنطقه خوفا من كارثه محتمله حسب وصفه
الاحداث والتطورات
بعد ساعات من مغادره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
عبرت سفينه تابعه للبحريه الامريكيه منطقه
تايوان في رساله مبطنه ربما للسلطات
الصينيه يا له من امر محير هل يريد ابناء
العم سام السلام مع اصحاب العيون الضيقه
ام اشعال التوترات مجددا قررت حكومه جنوب
السودان اغلاق حدودها مع السودان
لاعتبارات امنيه لكنها استثنت حركه عبور
النازحين وذلك بسبب تخوفات جوبا من انتقال
الحرب اليها نقلت وكاله بلومبرغ عن
مصادرها ان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
ورئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتينياهو يخططان للاجتماع للشهر المقبل
لتحسين العلاقات الفاتره بين البلدين
[موسيقى]